okay
so now we'd better get going with the
lecture okay so
um
we're now
at week eight second half of week four
um
so the agenda today is that i'm first of
all going to
finish off the last pieces of attention
that i didn't talk about last time
but the main topic today is to talk
about final projects and that'll consist
of uh sort of grab bag of different
things of talking about the final
projects and finding research topics and
finding data and doing research i'll
give a very brief introduction to
reading comprehension question answering
which is our default final project
but we get a whole lecture on that at
the beginning of week six so this is
just to give you a little bit of um what
it's about and if you're thinking about
doing the default final project um in
some sense this um lecture is also a
rare chance in this course um to pause
for breath because you know really we've
got
up until now been having the fire hose
going full stream ahead um spraying you
with new facts and approaches and
algorithms and models and linguistic
things um so this is a brief respite
from that so
if you have any questions that you've
been wondering about for weeks today's
lecture would be a good time to ask them
because after today's lecture in week
five
we'll turn the fire hose right back on
and we'll have a lot of new information
about transformers and large pre-trained
language models which have become a huge
part of modern neural nlp as i already
mentioned a little bit of
later into this class
okay so this is where we left things
last time basically
so
um i'd sort of talk through
the rough idea that what we're going to
do for this new attention model is that
we are going to use the encoder justice
before
and then once we're running the decoder
at each time step we're going to compute
a new hidden representation using the
same kind of sequence model as we had
before but now we're going to use that
hidden representation of the decoder to
look back at the encoder and it's going
to then
work out respectively some kind of
function of similarity between two
hidden states and decode hidden states
and based on those it's going to work
out what are called attention scores and
attention scores are actually
probability weights um as to how much it
likes
different elements and based on those
attention scores we're going to compute
an attention distribution um
so this is our probability distribution
and then based on that what we do is
compute a weighted average of the
encoder rnn hidden states weighted by
the attention distribution and so that's
going to give us a new attention output
vector which is like the hidden state
vector of the decoder that is an extra
hidden vector and so we're going to use
both of them to then um
generate our next output which is going
to be here the word pi at the end of the
sequence
um
so let's start off now by doing that
with some equations
um so
before you move on um there's a good
question here sorry
which is why is the encoder and decoder
both required as opposed to just the
same rnn for both i think yeah okay i'll
address that um so
well maybe there are a couple of still
possible interpretations for that but
i'll say something about it so you know
this
the basic case that we've been doing
here is this case of machine translation
where we've got um a source
um encoder which is in the source
language and we've got a target decoder
which is in the target language so since
these two things
small
using different languages it makes sense
to have separate sequence models with
different rnn parameters for each one
and at that point um it's
just a fact about what we want to do
with machine translation which is that
um well we actually want to look back at
the source to try and decide what extra
words to put into the translation so it
makes sense to attend back from the
source to the translation
but um
what you might be asking is well why do
we only do that why don't we also
consider doing attention from here back
into the dakota rnn and if that's um
what
you are thinking about that's a great
suggestion and actually very quickly
after these attention models were
developed that's exactly what people
started doing
they decided that well actually we could
start using more forms of attention and
we could also use a tension that looks
back in the decoder sequence and that
often gets referred to as self-retention
and self-attention has proven to be an
extremely powerful con concept and
indeed that then leads into
the transformer models um that we're
going to see next week
um
you know going in on things
i think of self-attention wasn't quite
as much an
obviously needed idea like from this
initial translation motivation which was
where attention was developed it seemed
fairly clear that when we're when you're
running the decoder rnn
that
as a conditional language model it gets
some information about the store spread
into its initial state then it seemed
pretty clear you were losing a lot of
information on
about the details of what was in the
fourth sentence and therefore be really
really useful have this idea of
attention so you could directly look at
it as you proceeded to translate
in a way it's a little bit less obvious
that you need that for the decoder rna
because after all
last week we introduced those really
clever lstms and the whole argument of
the lstm was actually they're pretty
good at maintaining history of a
sequence through quite a bunch of time
periods so to the extent that the lstm
is doing a perfect job maybe you
shouldn't really need self-attention in
your decoder but actually precisely
what's been shown is that this mechanism
of attention is a much more effective
method again of selectively addressing
elements of your past state and it's
sort of lighter weight rather than
having to kind of cook up the parameters
that your lsdm so it's carrying just the
right information forward all the time
you've provided you carry only enough
information that the model knows where
to look back to
you can then kind of grab more
information from past states when you
want to so that's actually a great
approach but i won't talk about it um
more now and
that will come up more
next week
the equations um hopefully these won't
actually seem difficult so what we have
is we have our hidden our encoder hidden
states which are vectors
um
on time step t we have a decoder hidden
state which is also a vector of the
hidden state dimension and then what we
want to do is get attention scores
as to
for st
how much attention
it play it pays for each of the hidden
states of the encoder and the easiest
way to do that is just to
use dot products between the source
and the sorry not the source the dot
products between the decoder hidden
state s and the encoders in state h so
these give us a bunch of numbers that
might be negative or positive but their
attention scores and so you know just
like we did right from the first lecture
with word vectors we then put those to a
soft max distribution and then we get a
probability distribution over the time
steps of the encoder
okay so now we've got that probability
distribution we can construct
a new vector by creating a weighted sum
of the encoder hidden states based on
these attention
um distribution probabilities and that
gives us
then to make use of that in generating
the output we're going to concatenate
the attention output with the decoder
hidden state sp so it now got something
of size 2h and then we're going to
proceed as with the non-attention model
we then put that through another stock
max to generate a probability
distribution of output words and then
with sample word
and um
hopefully that's sort of a fairly
obvious implementation of what we have
here so we've got our vectors with
encoder and decoder we've gained dot
products
of
st with each one
softnext turns them to a probability we
take the weighted average of the ones in
red to get the attention output we
combine that with
the
st
decoders hidden state and then we put it
through another soft max and we can
sample pi
okay um so
i sort of almost can't
stress enough attention is great
so the very first
modern neural machine translation
program
was done in 2014 um at google by ilya
sinsky bradau and they had a
straightforward
encoder decoder to lstms and by a bunch
of tricks of having very deep lspms huge
amount of data a huge amount of training
other tricks that i don't want to go
into now they were actually able to get
good results by just putting together
a straight seek to seek
new machine translation system but very
soon after that in fact later the same
year um a group from montreal
um about now
and joshua benjio introduced uh sequence
the sequence model with attention and it
was just obviously better so attention
significantly improves in your machine
translation performance and that sort of
makes sense um that allows the decoder
to focus on parts of the source
standards so i think of it as giving you
a much more human-like model of doing
machine translation because you know
exactly what a human translator would do
is you read the source sentence you've
got an idea of what's about you start
writing the first couple of words of the
translation and then what you do is is
you look back to see
what exactly it said as the sort of
modifiers of the noun to translate the
next few words
technically people think of it as
solving the bottleneck problem because
attention now allows us full access to
the entire source hidden state and we
can get any information that we need
it's not the case that all information
has to be encoded in the final hidden
state um it also helps with the
vanishing gradient problem so
effectively now we have shortcuts back
to every um hidden state of the encoder
and so therefore there's always a short
path for gradient flow and that greatly
mitigates the vanishing gradient problem
a final neat thing is that attention
provides some effective interpretability
to sequence the sequence models because
by
looking at the tension distribution we
can see what the decoder was focusing on
so in a soft probabilistic way we get
for free through the operation of the
model a soft alignment as to which words
translate which words so in this example
um of the french sentence is being
translated he hit me with a pie where
there's sort of a single verb here in
the french which is kind of i guess in
english sometimes people on pi day use
pies as the verbs that sort of like
saying he me pied
that the model you know is getting that
eel is translated as he
the
being translated as me and essentially
antarte is being translated as hit with
a pie
um
so
the amazing thing is you know
the model was never told about any of
these alignments there was no explicit
separate model which was trying to learn
these alignments as in earlier
statistical phrase-based systems we just
built a sequence the secret model with
the tension and said hear a lot of
translated sentences
start running back back prop and try and
get good
use of sentences and it just learns by
itself in deciding where it's best
to pay attention what is a good
alignment between the source and the
target languages
okay so
that's the basic
idea of um
attention
um i want to go a bit more into the
complexity of attention since it's a
such an important idea um that
we'll see a lot as we continue now with
the course right so
there are several attention variants but
first of all you know what's the common
part um so we have some values some
vectors that we're going to be sort of
using as our memory and we have a query
vector so attention always involves that
we calculate the attention scores
and turn those into a probability
distribution with a soft max
and we use the attention distribution to
calculate a weighted sum
of the elements in our memory giving us
an attention output
so the main place where you immediately
see variation in attention is
how do you compute these attention
scores
and so let's go through some of the ways
that that's done
so the simplest most obvious way to do
it um is to say let's just take the dot
product between the hidden st the
current hidden state of the decoder
and all of the vectors here the um
the source encoder vectors that we are
putting attention over and you know that
sort of makes sense right this is
dot product is our most basic similarity
score but
it seems like there's something wrong
with this and that is you know it seems
wrong for you to want to think that the
entirety of the source hidden states and
the entirety of the target hidden states
is all
having information about where to attend
to
because really these lstms are doing
multiple things so the lstms are
carrying forward information along their
own sequence to help you know record
information about the past so it can be
used in the future they have information
in the hidden state to tell you which
output you should generate next
and perhaps they're encoding some
information that will serve as a kind of
a query key for getting out information
by attention from the source hidden
states so it seems like probably we only
want to use some of the information in
them to calculate um our attention score
and so that's the kind of approach that
was taken very quickly in subsequent
work um
so the next year um tang long
working with me explored this idea
that's now normally called
multiplicative attention so for
multiplicative attention
we put an extra matrix
in the middle of our dot product so this
gives us a matrix of learnable
parameters and so effectively inside
this matrix we can learn what parts of s
to pay attention to and what parts of
each to pay attention to when
calculating the similarity and hence the
attention score
between the source hidden states and
then decode a hidden state um
so that was a is a good thing which in
general works much better but there's
perhaps a problem with that which is you
know maybe this w matrix has too many
parameters you know because we've got
these two vectors which in the simplest
case of both are the same dimension d
but they don't have to be the same and
you know we're now putting in d squared
new parameters for the matrix w and that
sort of feels like it's too many because
you know arguably it seems like we
should only have about 2d parameters you
know one d saying how much attention to
pain different parts of s and the other
one how much attention to pay to parts
of age
you know there's a reason for more by
having a whole matrix here you're not
only doing the scoring element wise
right you can you can have
any element of s being combined with any
element of the h vector and see that as
a useful part of your similarity score
but there's still a lot of parameters so
a bit after that um
here well maybe thing with less
parameters so if you have a matrix w and
you'd like it to have less parameters
the obvious linear algebra thing to do
is to say okay we can model w as u
transpose v
where u and v
are low rank skinny matrices so we can
choose some number k
for how skinny these matrices
are going to be and they can be k times
d
matrices and then we're getting a sort
of a reduced rank matrix here and so we
have a lot we end up with a d by d
matrix but it has a lot less parameters
in it
and so people explored that and you know
at that point um if you just do a little
bit of basic linear algebra what we have
here is exactly the same the
source hidden vector and the decoder
hidden vector um and
projecting each of them with a low rank
linear projection and then taking the
dot product of the of the projections
and if you remember this equation here
until next tuesday's lecture um you'll
see that that's actually exactly what's
happening in transformer models
um
but none of these were actually the
original form of attention that was
suggested by barnardo um what bud now um
suggested is the way we could calculate
the tension score is by taking the two
vectors multiplying each by a matrix
putting adding them putting through them
through a tan h function
giving us another vector which we then
dot product with yet another vector and
we get out of weight so um
in the literature that compares um
attention variance this one is normally
referred to as additive attention i've
always thought
that that's a really lousy name um well
at least it's never made sense to me
because really what you're doing here is
that you're using a new net layer to
calculate an attention score right this
looks just like the kind of neural net
layers that we use when we wanted to
calculate scores such as when we were
doing simple sort of feed-forward
networks at the beginning and we wanted
to calculate scores
okay um in assignment four um which you
should look at really soon if you
haven't looked at it yet um actually one
of the things in the written problems of
assignment four is thinking about um
these different attention
variants
okay um
yeah so i've only presented this idea of
attention
as something good for machine
translation to used between
the source and the target
sequence models except for that when
when i try to answer the question but
really this is a general deep learning
technique right so it's not only great
for that application you can use it in
many architectures not just sequence
sequence and you can use it for many
tasks not just for machine translation
so any time that you have a bunch of
vector values and you have some other
vector that you can regard as a query
attention as a technique
to compute a value from them
that you can have the query attend to
the values
and so you know once you think about it
like that you can think about attention
as a kind of memory access mechanism
that the weighted sum that attention
calculates gives you a kind of selective
summary of some of the information
contained in the values and the query
tells you
which values to pay attention to
so on the one hand you could say this is
a good general technique anytime you
have a whole bunch of
vectors and you want to just get one
vector out well you know the dumbest
thing you can do is just average them
all or do
max pooling take the element-wise max of
each element but this gives you a much
more flexible way to combine them
together in as to a single vector and so
you can think of it as actually giving
us an operation that's sort of much more
like a conventional computer and it's
memory access
so the values we can think of as like
our ram
and
um
like an associative memory right we have
a query vector and the query vector acts
as a sort of
associative memory pointer that says how
much weight to put on different parts of
ram and then we sort of proportionately
retrieve those bits around to get a new
value
um another cool thing about
attention that i'll just mention here um
is that
you know attention was actually a
genuinely new deep learning idea from
the last decade middle of the last
decade there's sort of a slightly
depressing fact about deep learning that
a lot of what's been done in deep
learning in recent years wasn't actually
new ideas there were ideas that were
developed in the 80s and 90s it's just
people weren't able to get much use of
them then because their computers were
too small and the amount of data they
had was too small and they were sort of
reinvented in the two well not
reinvented but they were given new life
in the 2010s
where attention is a genuinely um
new idea from the 2010s and we'll see
sort of um next
um next week how it sort of then turns
into this huge idea that transforms nlp
okay
so that's all i wanted to say about
attention um and now i want to
get on and go and talk about final
projects and all this stuff about that
um so am i good to start onto other
stuff
yes
yeah okay
um so this is a quick reminder so you
don't forget this is their coursework um
so you're
right in the
middle or past halfway almost of going
through um the assignments and they're
worth about half the grade but the other
half of the grade
comes from the final project which i'm
going to talk about today and that gets
split up um so there's a project
proposal which we've handed out the
instructions for today is worth five
percent there's a milestone that's worth
five percent in the middle
and there's a report at the end which is
the big part which is worth 30 percent
and then we also want to have a
representation of your project that
people can easily browse so in
normal years when there are people on
campus we had a poster session for the
class which just seems like we just
can't usefully do in the current world
we want to put up a website um where
there's sort of brief descriptions of
each
project some nice picture of what you've
done um and then we can link to your
project light up and so you'll also then
get three percent for that that's maybe
just make sure you do it when it comes
down to it um
right um and yeah so i should just
mention again as we go along
the honor code
that's important also
for the final projects so just to be
clear on that so for the final projects
in a lot of cases you're going to use a
lot of stuff that already exists that
you may well be using some model that
you can just download from the github
repository or similar places
you
may well be taking various ideas you
know it's fine for the final project to
use any amount of existing stuff
but you have to make sure that you
acknowledge what you're using and
document it and in terms of evaluating
your projects um what we'll be
interested in is the value add in terms
of what you did um not what you're able
to download from other people
so for the final project you can have
teams of one to three
um
in almost every case every member of the
team gets the same score but we do ask
for a brief statement of the work done
by each teammate and if it's clear that
there was sort of some egregious
imbalance in sort of one in a hundred
cases we do do something about that
okay so for the final project you've
essentially got two choices you can
either do our default final project
where um we give you the scaffolding and
said you pointed in some direction or
you can propose a custom final project
which we then need to approve as a
suitable final project for the course
and i'm going to talk a bit about both
of those in this class
so you can work in teams of one to three
if you have a bigger team we expect you
to do more
sometimes people use the same project
for multiple classes um so that it might
also use it as um
allow that but it's sort of the same
general rule right so they have two of
you and you're using the project for two
classes each that's sort of like it
should be four persons worth of work um
that is being done and so we expect you
know projects that are
bigger that
you know if it's just one of you we can
um be totally satisfied with something
compact and small you know so it has to
be done um but it can be compact and
small whereas if there are three of you
um we sort of feel like well you really
should have had enough time to actually
implement a variant model and see if
that works better
you can use any framework the language
you want for the final project
but in practice basically people go on
using pie torch um and then finally i've
got to mention on the default final
project i'll get back to this in a
minute but actually this year new thing
we've got two sub variants of the of the
default final project and you can choose
one or the other
um
so for custom final projects i'm really
happy to talk to people about um final
projects but there's this problem
and and you're encouraged to sign up for
an office hour slot um but there's this
problem there's only one of me um so
also encourage um you to um talk to
the tas about final projects many of the
tas have experience for all sorts of
things and we've tried to sort of
summarize some of what they have
experience
with
on the office hours page so look at that
and try and get some ideas of who might
be good to talk about um so for
the final projects we
make sure everyone has some kind of
mentor and the mentor can either be ta
or instructor in this class or it could
be somebody else and for the somebody
else option well you know if there's
someone you know at stanford and there's
some cool project they have you know
whatever it is if it's something
you know and the political science of
understanding documents or in the med
school doing something um
you can have them as your mentor or we
then also collected some projects from
people in the stanford nlp group and
community and we're going to be
distributing a list of those so you can
try and sort of sign up to be doing one
of those projects and they can be a
mentor so in that case the other person
we expect to be the mentor that's
keeping an eye on your project and
telling you to do something sort of
sensible um but it's one of the
tas in the class who will be grading
your various pieces of work for class
okay so these are the details um of the
two default final projects and the
handouts um for them they're about sort
of ten or so page handouts for each one
they're out on the web now um so there
are so both of them involve question
answering which i'll mention a bit at
the end
and there are sort of two variants
one is
for you to actually
build a question answering architecture
by yourself and i describe this as as
from scratch but it's not really from
scratch because we give you a baseline
question answering system in the starter
code but you're working doing all the
work of what else could i add to the
model how can i add extra layers
different attention and other things to
make it um better using squad data set
um
but one of the things that's happened in
nlp
which is really then the topic of next
week's classes and the last few years in
nlp there's been this revolution in
using
large
pre-trained language models with names
like birth roberta um
others which have just been sort of
fantastically good for doing natural
language problems so the other choice um
is to make use of those models and so
then effectively the model and the model
architecture as a starting point is
given to you and so then what we're
hoping to have people focus on is how to
build a robust question answering system
which works across different data sets
and domains so a huge problem with a lot
of nlp models is if you train them on
say wikipedia data they work great on
wikipedia data but then as soon as you
try and
use them on something else whether it's
customer support questions or web
questions that their performance
degrades greatly despite the fact that
that to the human being it seems like
you're doing
last answering and so
the building a robust qa system track
we're then going to be sort of um
training or fine-tuning um pre-trained
language models on several data sets and
your goal is to produce something that
then performs well on different data
sets
okay
so for this topic of question answering
i'm going to stay a few minutes on it at
the end but on tuesday of week six um
the entire lecture is on question
answering so there'll be a lot of
content there on the different kinds of
models um for really getting up to speed
good stuff to know even if you're not
doing the default final projects it's a
major application of nlp but even better
stuff to know if you are doing um the
final project so look out for that but
just to give you one example this is the
kind of thing we have a
question-answering
problems so question answering is
taking a paragraph of text but i only
put one sentence to keep my slides short
um bill laken adopted by mexican movie
actress luca
mayorga grew up in the neighboring town
of the madera and his song chronicled
um the question is in what town did bill
aiken grew up this doesn't actually seem
so hard um i presume all of you could
have done this when you were in sixth
grade in school or something like that
the answer should be madeira
but somehow google's bert model um fails
to find that answer um perhaps you know
it's partly because there's extra stuff
in the middle there adopted by mexican
movie actress
um and so it says no this sentence
doesn't answer the question so you can
hope to do better than that
okay um so there's this choice about
doing either the default or custom final
project um and you know the overall
stats have been that about half the
people do each um so there's no sort of
clear winner of a choice
in terms of thinking about
what you should choose i mean i think
the default final project is great if
you have limited experience with doing
research if you don't have any clear
idea of what you would want to do as a
custom final project if you think it'd
be good have you know guidance and a
clear goal to work towards indeed we
give you a leaderboard so you can
compete against the other people during
the final project um then you should do
the default final project it gives you
guidance scaffolding clear um goal posts
i mean and in particular just to sort of
try and um give a sharper edge to this i
mean you know
the fact of the matter is every year
there are a few people who do
um a custom final project and when we're
grading them we look at this custom
final project and um
we say huh you know this just looks
pretty lame compared to what people are
doing in the default final project and
that's a bad state to be in right if
you're doing the custom final project
you want to have a sort of a clear thing
that you've thought out that is
interesting so it will seem as or more
interesting
than the default final project and if
you don't think you've got such a thing
you're actually better off doing the
default final project
um why should you do the custom final
project
well if you have some research project
possibly something you've already been
working on or any rate something that
you think oh this would be great to do
um which there are two requirements for
our project it has to substantively
involve human language and it has to
substantively involve neural networks so
that doesn't mean it has to be fully
about those if you want to do a language
and vision project that's fine um or if
you want to compare neural networks
versus other machine learning methods on
some problem that's fine but you do have
to in your project substantively um use
both of those things um
yeah so if you'd like to sort of design
your own thing and come up with
something different on your own or just
you don't like question answering um
or if you basically want more experience
of going through the whole process of
trying to find a good research goal
finding data and tools to explore it
working out on your own then doing the
custom final project
is a great choice
okay
either way
um the steps that you go through are the
following so the first thing
which you've gone to fib 16 for is to
write a project proposal um which is
three
pages
so
you know
how did some of the details vary on the
kind of project so you need to decide on
the research
topic for your
project which is kind of easy if you're
doing the final project it's either a or
b
but we then want you to choose one
research paper that's relevant to your
final project
read it and
then
learn some stuff from it that you can
write about
and we want you to write about what your
plan is what you're going to do about
the final project and that will include
describing things as needed such as the
data and the evaluation and again this
is especially important for custom final
projects
might be kind of obvious um if you're
doing a default final project
and so typically if you're doing a
default final project
this should be three pagers and if
you're doing a custom final project this
should be four pages
um so
there are two parts of that the first
part of it is
writing about the paper you read and so
that part is two pages and so we they're
a longer form of the instructions but we
want you to sort of read and think about
this paper you know what are its novel
contributions
is that an idea that could be
employed in other ways are there things
that didn't really do well um
how does it compare to other ways that
people have approached this problem does
it sort of
suggest even though it did things one
way does it actually suggest ideas that
really could do things a different way
that might even be better and so um
we want you to write this
two-page paper summary which we will
grade and effectively we're going to
grade that on how good a job you do at
thinking about analyzing and having um
critical comments on this paper
so then the other half which might be
longer or shorter now depending on this
custom or default is
to propose what you're going to do
um
and
really this part is formative so
formative means we're not going to grade
it harshly we want you to write it so we
can help you um so we want you to sort
of thought through what you're going to
do and the first have an opportunity to
say no that's unrealistically large or
that sounds insufficiently ambitious or
this isn't going to work unless you can
get more data than you actually have and
things like that um so
um this is mainly just for feedback but
you know on the things to think about
you know for project plans that are
lacking they're they're generally just
lacking concreteness in nuts and bolts
ways which are essential for being able
to do a good final project in a short
amount of time so
you need to have found good data or have
a realistic plan so that should be
planned a realistic plan to be able to
collect that um you need to have a
realistic way that you can evaluate your
work
you need to have thought about what
kinds of experiments you could run so
you could show whether your model is
working well or badly and will be sort
of looking to see whether you've done
those things
okay so then a couple of weeks after
that
is the project milestone which is again
from everyone um this is a progress
report this is again just meant to help
keep you on track um so you should be
more than halfway done um you should
have
been able in nearly all cases i'll talk
about more about this in a minute in
nearly all cases you should already have
been able to implement some baseline
system and have some initial
experimental results to show you know
you might still be working on your main
model and have nothing to show it but
hopefully you've at least said an
obvious simple baseline to know how well
it works is this thing and i've built
that and i have some numbers and then we
want an update on how you plan to spend
the rest of your time and again a lot of
this is about us giving you more
feedback as to what are the best things
you could do
for the final two weeks of a class
um and then at the end there's writing
up um the final
um project
and
so
for this
um
you know the quality of your write-up is
really really important to your grade
right you know by and large we're going
to evaluate how good your project is by
reading the writer so make sure you
budget sufficient time to actually um
do a good job
now i do um you could look at good
projects from past years they're all up
on the cf24n website um 2020 was kind of
a mess because of the start of the
pandemic so it's possible you should
look at 2019 there's even better models
of what you should do
um so
you know the details vary but this is
sort of a picture to have in mind of
normally
what the write-up looks like so you know
eight pages you want to have an abstract
introduction to the paper you want to
talk about related prior work you want
to present the model you're using you
want to talk about the data you're using
talk about your experiments what the
results are what you learned about it
you know the details may
vary you know some papers there's less
to say about the model and there's more
to say about the experiments so you can
sort of move things around a bit but
roughly something like this
okay
so
um
i now want to kind of go on and say a
bit about research and practical things
that we need to do
a lot of these things are relevant to
everybody at any rate there are things
that you should know a little bit about
so the very first one is finding
research topics which is sort of
especially um vital
to custom final projects
yeah so
really for all of science there's sort
of only two ways that you can have a
research project that one way
is
doing domain science where you start
with a problem of interest in the domain
such as how can i build a decent
cherokee to an english machine
translation system and you work on
finding ways to be able to do it better
than people currently know how to do
or to understand the problem better than
people currently understand that and the
other way is to take a methodological
approach where you start off with some
method or approach of interest and then
you work out good ways to extend or
improve it or new ways to apply it and
so basically you're doing
one of those
so there are effectively different kinds
of projects you can do
this is not an exhaustive list but most
projects sort of fall into one of these
buckets very non-uniformly
so
the most common type is you find some
application or task of interest and you
explore how to approach and solve it as
well as possible often that's using
existing models and trying out different
options and things like that the second
kind
is you can take some relatively complex
neural architecture i.e it has to be
something more complex than we've built
for assignments one through five you
implement it
and get something that works on some
data
and you know if i you're doing something
fairly complex it's fine just to
implement it and get it to work
but you know if there's some way that
you can tweak it and try and do
something different and see if that
makes it even better or maybe it makes
it worse and you can do experiments
either way um that's sort of even better
um there are then other kinds of
projects that you can do so another kind
of project is an analysis project so you
can take some model that's an existing
model and you can poke at it and find
out things about what it knows so you
could take anything even as simple as
word vectors and poke at them and you
can find out things like well how much
these word vectors know about word
senses
well sometimes the same word is both a
noun and a verb can you tell those
can you sort of get that
different similarities out of the word
vectors so analysis projects are
perfectly fine often interesting um and
then of these five times the rarest kind
of project we've had a couple is a
theoretical project
so you know there's a lot of interesting
deep learning theory is that
how do these things work and why and
what would it take to make it work
better
and so you can work on sort of getting
any kind of non-trivial property or
understanding of a deep learning model
here are just quickly a couple of
examples of some projects
from past years with 224 end just gives
you a couple of examples of things like
this so
deep poetry
this was
doing generation of shakespearean
sonnets um so the way it was being
generated was with the clan
list
and what to work with now
for
machine translation but it had
interesting differences because if you
wanted to generate poetry you need to
know about metrical structure and rhyme
and so they're working out how to add
components to a model that could do that
here's someone who was
implementing a complex newer model so
there's been a line of work um at
deepmind on trying to build um general
purpose computers as neural
architectures and there's first of all
neural turing machines and then a
subsequent
model called the differential ball
neural computer
and they haven't released the code of
those open source um so carol decided
that she was going to re she was going
to implement differential neural
computers and get them to work um this
was a very dangerous idea
because you know we were in week 10 of
the class and she still hadn't gone to
work at all but luckily
she got it together at the last moment
and actually got her model working and
was able to run it and get results on
some of the problems that deep minds had
also shown results on um and so um she
pulled the rabbit out of the hat and had
an enormous success and we were very
impressed that she managed to do that
um
here's uh so sometimes final projects
have become papers um here's a final
project that became
a paper published at the top machine
learning conference this is from a few
years ago this one from 2017.
it actually has a couple of fairly
simple ideas but you know there are
ideas that at that time people weren't
using and these two people proved worked
and improved things and they got
a conference paper out of it so i'll
just mention one of them now
so if you think about our current neural
network language models they have both
and
from words and encoding into
distributed vectors now at the other end
you know the softmax matrix basically
hides inside it just like for our word
vectors a word vector for each word and
then you're sort of deciding the
probabilities of generating different
words based on similarities between um
the um
a query vector in each of those words so
their idea was look maybe we'd actually
be able to build better language models
if we tied together the word embedding
matrix
and
the matrix used to project the rnn
output um and actually they showed that
you can get um significant gains by
doing that and so now you know
it's basically sort of now becomes
standard if you're wanting to build
strong
newer language models that you want to
tie those two sets of parameters
together so that was pretty cool
um
here's a more system z project um so
i'll mention this again later but you
know something people have been
interested in is how can you squish
neural nets and make them small um so
you can run them on
you know a regular laptop or a smaller
device like a mobile phone and so um
these people um worked on
how could you do quantization
of neural networks down sort of one or
two bits per parameter and still get um
good results um so this is sort of an
example of has to involve neural nets
and human language there's sort of a way
in which you could say this didn't
involve human language at all um because
this was so really about quantizing your
nets but you know effectively where we
draw the line is we say you will be
allowed to do this providing the task
that you
the task and model you use to
demonstrate success or failure is a
natural language task and so they um did
both word similarity tasks and question
answering tasks of seeing how long the
system performed after doing the
compression by quantization
um
how can you find a good place for a
project if you don't have a good idea um
one place is to sort of look at recent
papers so for most nlp papers they
appear in the acl anthology um also look
at major machine learning conferences um
most past 224 n projects are up on the
class website you can look through them
there's just general archive.org
servers
but perhaps even better is looking for
an interesting problem in the world
so how variant is an economist um was it
the
please
now and he wrote this cool paper that i
often recommend come to
the students of how to build an economic
model in your spare time and the paper
isn't really about economic models it's
about how to um do research and what he
says right at the beginning um
section one of the paper is called
getting ideas
and he writes um but where to get ideas
that's the question
most graduate students are convinced
that the way you get ideas is to read
journal papers but in my experience
journals really aren't a very good
source of original ideas you can get
lots of things from journal papers
technique insight even true but most of
the time you will only get somebody
else's ideas um and so he sort of talks
about
further about better ways of getting
ideas by thinking about problems in the
world
um so for archive is this huge
repository of papers it's hard to
navigate um there are various tools that
can make it easier to navigate one of
them is archive sanity preserver
which is a website that was written by
andrei capathy who was the original
person who constructed and taught the
cs231 n course um still a good thing to
use
um
there are lots of leaderboards for
different tasks in nlp um so a place you
can find tasks and work on tasks is
looking at leaderboards um so papers
with code and nlp progress are two good
general sources of leaderboards there
are also then lots of more specialized
ones um for particular tasks
i wanted to then for research topics um
this material these next four slides are
brand new for this year i wanted to sort
of just say a few words about the kind
of
the funny somewhat different time that
we're in
where there's sort of old deep learning
nlp
and new deep learning nlp
so in the early days of the deep
learning revival which i'll call 2010 to
2018 because 2010's the year i started
doing deep learning for nlp
most of the work
was in defining and exploring better
deep learning architectures
so the typical paper was you know i can
improve a summarization system but not
by not only using the kind of attention
i just explained but i could add an
extra kind of attention which i'll use
as a copying mechanism so i'll do
additional attention calculations to
work out um
source words which i could copy verbatim
to the output rather than having to
regenerate them through the standard
kind of softmax that's just one example
of a millions but you are changing the
architecture of the model and make
things better um you know that's what a
lot of good cs224n projects um did too
and in particular you know
for
one branch of the default final project
the one where you start with the
baseline squad question answering system
um and work out ways to make it better
by adding more neural architecture it's
essentially doing this
um
but actually if you look out um
in
the research world of the last couple of
years
the sad truth is
that approach is dead no
it's not actually dead i mean that's too
strong
um
but
that's now
much more difficult and rarer to do
um if you look at the sort of last three
years of nlp
and this is true
both for people who are implementing
production nlp systems at companies
and for people who are doing research in
nlp
that most work is more like this
there are these enormous
enormously good
big pre-trained language models bert gpt
2 roberta excel net t5
they exist on the web and you can
download them
with one python command and they give
you a great basis for doing most nlp
tasks we'll learn all about them next
week um so you're not actually
starting from scratch to finding your
own model architecture and playing with
variants you're saying i'm going to be
using roberta
further fine tuning it for your task
doing domain adaptation
and things like that
um so you know
this is so very quickly for
2021 nlp for all of your practical
projects and industry needs this is
basically the formula that which you
should probably use um there's this
enormously great library by the company
hugging face um you install it pip
install transformers and then that gives
you a great implementation of the
transformers we learn about next week
and then effectively what you're doing
is something like my code below um this
code doesn't quite run it's missing some
pieces if you try it but you know the
sort of pieces are you load a big um
pre-trained language model so here i'm
loading the birthday sun case model um
it turns out these models all hats have
very special tokenizers you'll hear
about those next week as well so we grab
the tokenizer for it um then we're going
to fine it for our tasks like maybe i'm
going to be working with legal data so i
want to take the general model and
fine-tune it to understand legal data
better um and then i've got something i
want to do
like question answering or perhaps here
where i'm using bert for sequence
classification maybe the task i want to
do is label
mentions of sections of legal code so at
that point
i'm then going to
sort of fine-tune for that particular
task and then run on that task
and so this is kind of what we're doing
and we're just sort of
doing stuff on top of a pre-existing
model
so a lot of what is exciting now is
problems that work within or around
that world
so
um and you might sort of think about
that and look at recent papers and
things that could be done about that
world well one of them and this is the
other half of the default final project
is we still have this problem of
robustness to domain shift that these
models are trained on normally one kind
of text but we often want to use it for
different kinds of text including often
when you're talking about problem or
application specific
questions their domains but you don't
have much data how can you do that well
um
if you've got one of these big models
well in some sense they're good but are
they actually you know robust that they
work for all of the different things in
the space you'd like them to work on so
you're not only interested in basic
accuracy but robustness so this
robustness gym
was a very recently announced project
um by a phd student at stanford current
girl um it's actually testing the
robustness of nlp models and they've got
some stuff built into it but there's
lots of stuff that isn't built into it
if someone would like to sort of choose
some nlp problem whether it's dependency
parsing or something else like
summarization and build out robustness
tests for it that could be kind of
interesting to do um
you know a bunch of other things you can
look at issues um whether there's bias
embedded in these models um how can you
explain what they're doing um how can
you use data augmentation there's been
an enormous amount of work on
using data augmentation to improve model
resources
lots of different areas
i'll just mention two other things
and then i'll go on
so it's been a ton of work on scaling
models up and down
so these big pre-trained language models
are already big
so the fact of the matter is
it's just not possible for the time and
resources that you have in 224n to be
thinking i'm going to be building by
myself um
big
um pre-trained models all you can do is
use ones that already exist but you know
on the other hand people are actually
interested in can you but
build very small models that still work
pretty well and you know there are lots
of examples but actually one that was
done recently for question answering was
that there was a bake off competition at
the last europe's which was called
efficient qa and one of the divisions of
this
bake off was can you
can you build a performant question
answering system that will run
in 500
and well you know that's actually a
reasonable thing that you could attempt
um for a final project um another thing
people have been very interested in is
wanting to explore
more advanced learning capabilities um
in neural networks ideas like
compositionality systematic
generalization fast learning such as
meta learning work and a lot of the time
people have investigated these
in small domains so here's a couple of
examples that you go look at baby ai and
g scan so those could be kind of
interesting places you can look um for a
final project
okay other stuff to know quickly um
probably i can't quite go through all of
these slides and some of them you could
just take home and look at
you need data um
now we actually love it if people feel
like they can collect their own data and
sometimes they're good ways to collect
your own data
and but you know
the reality is a lot of the time the
easiest way to get a fast start on a
final project when you only have a few
weeks is to make use of an existing data
set and there are lots of pre-existing
data sets so there's data from the
linguistic data consortium which is
licensed data we have licenses at
stanford you can look through their
catalog and find all the things they
have there are websites that have lots
of data so if you want to do machine
translation tasks you can find lots of
machine translation data on this website
dependency parsing if you're keen on
assignment three lots of data on the
universal dependencies website there are
now several
websites that are collecting a lot of
data sets so hugging face has also just
recently actually announced hugging face
data sets which is sort of an index of
data sets and the papers with code
people also have papers with code data
sets so you can look at those um there
are many more um
yeah
um
here's just a
quick um summary
of thinking about a research
project so you know this is just one
example right that suppose you think
summarization so that's sort of going
from a longer piece of text to a short
summary of that so you know what you
have to do you need to you know find the
data set and well probably the easiest
thing to do is to sort of use an
existing text summarization data set you
can find several online but you know
this is where you can think of
interesting ways to create your own data
so something that you might have noticed
if you look at twitter is that
journalists often promote their own
stories by or their
their newspaper or tv station does by
putting out a tweet and so that's sort
of like found data which is sort of
self-summaries could you collect some of
those and try and learn to generate
tweets for a new story
um
so i'll say a bit about data set hygiene
you want to be careful about working
things out so you have
trained sets and test sets i'll say that
in a minute you want some way to
evaluate whether you're doing it well as
you build models and you pretty much
need to have an automatic evaluation
metric even though human evaluation is
great since you want to train a bunch of
models and see whether better or worse
you normally want an automatic metric
that's semi-decent
you should make sure you have some kind
of baseline um
that you want to have some sense of
whether you're doing well and so
commonly you first off want to implement
some simple model like a logistic
regression or
just averaging word vectors or something
and see how well that works because then
you know if you're not doing better than
that that you're actually making no
progress whatsoever
then you should implement some new net
model and see if you can
that you think might be good and see if
you can get that to work um and have
that work well
um
make sure you keep looking at your data
um to see what kind of errors you're
making and think about how you could
change the model to avoid them
and then hopefully you've got time to
try out some model variants and see if
they're better or worse and then that
will help in having a good project
um yeah so quickly um what i call here
pots of data um so
many public data sets come with a
structure where they have train dev and
test
and the idea is that you keep your test
data until the end and you only sort of
do test runs when development is
complete or at least almost complete
and
train on the train data and you evaluate
on the dev data um sometimes you need
even more data sets sometimes you want
to do tuning of hyper parameters and you
might need a train set a tune set a dev
set and a test set if the data set
if doesn't come pre-split or it doesn't
have enough pieces it's sort of your job
to work out how to cut it into pieces um
and to get things working and the reason
why you need to do this
um
is
that it's necessary to have these
different sets to get
realistic measures of performance in
fact ideally you're only actually
testing on the test set once
and at any rate very few times so if
you're doing the default final project
we limit you to three runs on the test
set so remember that and save your three
runs and the reason that we do that is
that if you sort of mix up and overuse
these data sets the results just become
invalid so you know when you train on
data well you always build a model that
does well on the training data so that's
not exciting um and well if you want to
tune hyper parameters if you tune them
on the training data set you won't get
good valid values for them because
they're not tuned to good values for
something that would work on different
test data
but the subtlest part of it is you know
i think a lot of people starting off
think oh there's no harm in just keeping
on testing on the test set every time i
you know try out some variant um i'll
just see how it's going on the test set
it's a really compelling thing that you
want to do right you changed your model
you'd like to know whether made the
score on the test set um go up or down
but you know the truth is that if you
do that
you're cheating because what you do
is you're sort of slowly training on the
test set because you keep every change
that helps on the test set and you throw
away every um change that doesn't help
on the test set or makes it worse and so
you're learning about the test set and
what things happen by chance to work on
that particular
test set so you're effectively slowly
training on the test set and you get
biased unrealistically high um
levels of performance
okay um
let's see
um
i think they're then
sort of a bunch more slides on neural
nets that i think i'm um going to just
um
skip for the moment but i think in
general they're useful to have seen um
maybe i'll just sort of
mention this one
so for the final projects you're much
more on your own and you have to
work out for yourself how to get your
new network to work
so
the first thing
is you want to start with a positive
attitude you know these neural nets are
amazing they really want to learn they
want to find any pattern they can
anywhere in data
they really just do that it's in their
dna so if your neural network isn't
learning it means you're doing something
wrong that's preventing it from learning
successfully
but you know at that point there's a
grim reality um there are all sorts of
things that cause neural nets to not
learn at all
or the more common case actually is they
sort of learn a bit that they don't
learn very well you know there are bugs
in the code you're dividing through by
the wrong thing
you're missing some connections in your
network so no information is flowing
from one place to another place um
you're calculating the gradients wrong
in some layer there are all sorts of
things that can
go wrong
so you need to then work out how to find
and fix them and the truth is that this
debugging and tuning can often take
way more time than i'm going to
implement the model so in terms of
thinking about how much you could get
through you should be thinking okay i've
coded up my model that doesn't mean that
you're 75 done it's pretty frequent it
means that you're only 20 done and
there's still a lot of work
to go to get things working
okay
so for the last minutes i just want to
say a few minutes um about
the final project so we've got some idea
about what this is about as an nlp
problem
okay so the problem
is
most commonly called question answering
over documents but really what the part
that we're doing is perhaps better
called reading comprehension
and so the idea of this is that you want
to actually be able to answer questions
based on documents
so here's an example of a question who
was australia's third prime minister
and you know once upon a time when if
you typed the question um into google
all you got was web search and it
returned to you a list of pages with the
implied promise that some of the ones
right near the top probably had the
answer to the question
but if you do this now
it gives you back an answer
and so here's the answer john christian
watson
and the important thing to realize is
that this kind of featured snippet you
know google has a 101 or maybe a
thousand one different pieces inside it
but you know this featured snippet isn't
coming from the google knowledge graph
structured data it's coming straight
from a web page where
some part of the google search system
has actually read this web page and
decided what the answer is
so for this kind of system the most
straightforward way to do it is you have
two parts first you have a web search
system that finds a page that probably
has the answer and then you have a
reading comprehension system that
actually looks inside the text and
works to extract the answer and so um
it's look through this piece of text and
this sentence says was an australian
politician who served as the third prime
minister of australia that's what i'm
asking for and slightly different word
in australia's third prime minister
this answers the question and so it
correctly says that the answer is john
christian watson and so what we want to
build in the default final project is
systems that do that second part that
given
a piece of text and a question they can
give the answer and so the general
motivation for why this is important is
once we have massive um
full text document collections that you
know simply with saying here's a list of
maybe relevant documents it's of limited
use that we'd really much prefer to get
answers to our questions and you know
that's true in general but you know it's
especially true if you're using your
phone to try and look for information
rather than sitting in front of a
27-inch monitor it's especially true if
you're using a virtual assistant device
like alexa or google assistant
so um that's the problem
um that's been worked on
um
reading comprehension or question
answering and so the squad data set
which was built by pranav raj parker and
percy liang
consists of passages taken from
wikipedia and questions which team won
super bowl 50 and what you're meant to
be able to do is read through this
passage
and say aha the answer is the denver
broncos
um and so there are a hundred thousand
such examples and so the answer
is always just taken to be a span of the
passage and that's referred to as
extractive question answering
so to collect this data what was done um
was that people were shown passages
asked several questions just like
reading comprehension at school perhaps
slightly simpler questions
and they were asked to choose a span
that answered it
and you know as in these examples show
the they showed it to three human beings
and they didn't always choose exactly
the same span because so there's some
uncertainty as to how many words to
include but roughly um they're answering
the question in that way
and so then we have evaluation measures
and so there are two evaluation measures
one is exact match whether you return
exactly what one of the humans returned
and the other one is the f1 measure
which is
um
is the overlapping words of your span to
one of the humans roughly
um
so for squat the initials
was always a question we're going to do
squad 2.0 which is just a little bit um
more complex because they make it a
little bit trickier that some of the
questions have no answers in the text so
here's a piece of text about genghis
khan and the question is
when did genghis khan kill great khan
and well if we sort of read through
this um text this genghis khan at the
beginning and there's um
talk about different khans and there's
the person down here who became great
khan in 1251 but ginger's khan didn't
kill great khan it doesn't say that at
all um but you know
actually here's microsoft nlmet which is
another strong question answering system
and if you ask at this um question it
says 12 34. so the reality is that a lot
of these models um have effectively
heuristically behave like okay well this
is asking for a year um let me look for
a year in this passage this near
discussion of genghis khan
and maybe weakening is somehow similar
to killing i'm going to guess 12 34 and
that's sort of the wrong thing to have
done here so this is a good reliability
test for question answering models so
that's an interesting add-on problem to
look at
okay
i'm going to stop there for today
good luck with your projects